what's up guys
bang bang it's lunch money time
well while she's trying to get rich for
us let's just trying to get a lunch
money right i'm here with the beautiful
intelligent pelina pompliano that's
right it's just popping on them now
uh what do what was i supposed to talk
about oh uh lunch money is now sponsored
by blockfi
they're awesome go get a blog fire
account block five dot com block five
dot com slash pomp
block five dot com slash pomp
blackfy.com
just go get an account eight point six
percent apy and an interest bearing
account
i'm on the board i'm an investor i'm a
user i'm happy you'll be happy go get it
go get money get paid
by five.com are you cold today no
well you got it zipped up to your chin
okay a lot of things just went through
my head but i ain't gonna play that i
got that friday energy today
how many hours did you sleep eight sleep
experiment going well
more to come soon i slept for like nine
and a half because i couldn't sleep and
then i had to
sleep experiment going well okay
ready yep so billionaire investor leon
cooperman
told cnbc on friday that he was
concerned about the long-term outlook
for the stock market
because too much debt is being created
maybe maybe what stock market doesn't
really gain value everybody knows that
what you mean since 1971 if you
denominate the stock market in dollars
it's a 45 degree angle straight uh up
and to the right um and it's like very
scary i mean there's
there's dips and stuff right but it's
basically 45 degrees uh straight up into
the right over
decades of inflation if you denominate
the same stock market in gold
it's down
so actually stock market hasn't gained
value is that that gold
error that the dollar is being devalued
and so uh when he says stock
yes from a value standpoint most likely
that's true but uh the price of stocks
will continue to go up because there
will be massive devaluation of the
dollar
okay can we talk about my favor oh
no there's another favorite second
favorite story of the day
the department of justice is looking to
block
visa's planned acquisition of fintech
startup plaid
on grounds that it would limit
competition in the payments industry do
you guys remember
when visa moved it bid with ma outbid
mastercard
and acquired plan for
5.3 billion dollars which was insane
and so the doj says that for anti-trust
reasons
that deal must be stopped because
the deal would extend a visa monopoly on
debit transactions i don't know i don't
know about this
mastercard's out there it's not it's a
dude it's a dual op
it's a duo they're saying monopoly i i
understand that but
what what is visa's um
uh chokehold on debit transactions i
don't know i bet you it's high
yeah i mean look this is like a legit
monopoly compare like
comp saying facebook is a monopoly is uh
no it's not facebook is not a monopoly
not even close
why not because there's all these other
social networks out there
there's all these other debit card
providers out there there's not
that's the whole thing there is no
because they have anti-competitive
practices like they'll go in and they'll
say
uh hey like if you use our payment
processor uh you can't go ahead
and use others like contractually like
they'll box other people out they'll do
all kinds of stuff right
and so wow 70 so visa has a 70
share of the debit market in the us
okay they have 70 percent mastercard 30.
mastercard no mastercard has another
a good amount of the rest but the whole
thing is mastercard can't grow uh
because visa the way that they structure
a lot of this stuff it's just like
this is much clearer of a monopoly
situation than i think the social
networks that's
okay why are you sad today i'm not i'm
great i got that friday energy trust me
i ain't sad at all i'm about to do this
i got to do a call in 15 minutes
after my call in 15 minutes then i'm
gonna go on a walk and i'm
i may walk around new york city i forgot
to talk about one topic that was at the
top so but now i'm gonna put in the
middle election forgot
um election is happening
my home state of georgia it's crazy out
there i don't know what's happening
but it's a very close election if you
ever thought
the us was divided here we are 49 and 49
i think this is going to be the last
comment i make about the election
or politics for a very long time
what i'm going to say is whoever ends up
being the president
we're all going to get behind they are
the leader of our country
we live in the best country in the world
i had a phone call yesterday
with a friend i had a phone call
yesterday with a friend and that friend
reminded me of something very important
we live in the best country in the world
what is going on here in the united
states would be
the desires of people who live in other
countries
the fact that we have democracy that we
have voting
that we're not out in the streets
killing each other over
any sort of uh disagreements the fact
that
there's free speech that i can sit here
and i can share my opinion
without any fear of repercussion and you
can do the same
america is still the greatest country in
the world america is still
the most free country in the world the
american dream
is still alive anyone anywhere in the
world
can come here regardless of where you
come from
what language you speak what your
religion is what your sexuality is
what the color of your skin is you can
come to the united states
and you can build a life of wealth and
happiness
and it's because we live in the most
democratic
free country in the world so stop
bitching
stop complaining and remember we're
lucky
and if you believe that there is some
better system somewhere else
then go there but the reason why you're
still living here
is because this is the best country in
the world and regardless of who the
president is
they're our leader let's go stop
the nonsense and let's just go back to
living life
being happy and continuing to progress
or progress the world that we live in
that's it
yeah i mean hallelujah
go america is there a better
what's the next thing yeah
see immigrant right here happy okay
yeah i see you smiling all right um
match group the owner of tinder
and hinge which is separate uh people
are continuing to flock to dating apps
tinder and hinge in droves to help fill
the social void as the coronavirus
stretches through the fall people at
first were like now i'm not getting on
that app
and now they're flocking um should i get
one on
oh wait match does own hinge i did not
know that
match group the company that owns tinder
hinge okay cupid and more
wow okay reported better than expected
earnings on wednesday
they saw so tinder saw revenue growth 15
since the third quarter in the app got a
16
boost when it comes to subscribers i
just heard that did you just say if you
can get on
hinge well i'm lonely
kidding
[Music]
oh okay but yeah so that's cool
i got you to annoy me no problem all
right
i i think that's interesting peloton
says recent
spike and covet cases lockdowns are
boosting its sales
yeah of course peloton's popping the
best thing my brother just wrote a a
big uh breakdown of this uh and i when i
was reading through it the craziest part
is the churn rate on a monthly basis is
less than one percent
less than one percent churn rate uh for
peloton which means
you were more likely to switch your cell
phone carrier
than you are to quit the peloton
subscription
that's nuts people don't ever switch
when's the last time you switch your
cell phone carrier
people don't do that but you're more
likely to do that than you are to quit
if you've got a peloton subscription
pretty nuts elon musk has already gotten
people to buy
flamethrowers short shorts and
surfboards now he's throwing in some
tequila
too musk's electric automaker tesla
launched its own line of tesla tequila
on thursday making good on the ceo's
promise for the company
to start selling its own brand of liquor
and it's already sold out
it sells for 250 dollars comes in a
lighting
lightning shaped bottle and is produced
by
nosotros tequila i like this why
because wait what does a car have oh
that's cool oh yeah it looks cool huh
yeah should we buy one yeah they are
yeah but you can buy them on ebay there
people are flipping them
the the whole thing that is uh is so
funny about it is just like
everyone's like oh you joking around
stop joking around supposed to be the
ceo of a big company he's like no i'm
not joking like here's the short shorts
like here's the tequila here's the
surfboards
right they didn't care he's literally
just playing around with people
i love him tesla kila i love it
awesome okay i do not have a joke for
today
but i do have a funny story yesterday we
were watching
the bachelorette no actually i got him
to watch the bachelorette with me
and um he was doing it like he was
watching a football game
get get me to watch is a uh uh
very nice way of putting it she took my
computer
put it on my computer so i couldn't do
work on my computer
and then made me sit there and watch it
with her he wanted to watch it guys he
wanted to watch it
and he was watching at like a football
game he was like
let's go no i was not saying that but i
was like
bam that dude's winner winner i was
cheering for them like a football team
hey listen if you have a competition i
told her already i would win
winners win okay i'd go right up and i'd
just be like okay
oh boy win all right win that's it for
lunch money today guys see you too
how annoyed are you with me right now on
a scale of one to ten
yeah on a scale one to six fifty eight
fifty eight okay that's good
and it's lower than usual usually like
an eighty uh am i gonna make it to
monday just tell the people so that
because if you promise them i'll survive
till monday sunday friday yeah i know
that you'll uh they'll keep your promise
we'll see no nobody like somebody who's
wishy-washy don't be a politician just
like
either yes or no what if you only see me
on monday
yes all right guys i'm safe see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest
on an interest-bearing account or you
can buy and sell cryptocurrencies on
their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends